[Musique]
c'était jour de fête à voici un agent et
à la nation avec une fanfare des
flonflons des discours comme pour toutes
les inaugurations
il y avait des ministres des pdg des
directeurs et sous-directeurs bref un
millier de personnalités et le train
bien sûr la vigne de nation à boissy
saint léger qui vient d'être inaugurée
sera ouverte au public dimanche dans
quelques semaines au mois de février
nous ouvrirons la section étoiles
défense de ce même réseau régional
deux ans après 171 nous viendrons à
l'opéra et fin 71 à 72 en iran jusqu'à
saint germain derrière cette carte la
vie de dizaines de milliers de gens qui
va être bouleversée des habitudes
changer comme pour cette jeune
banlieusarde qui a comparé avec nous
les deux voyages l'ancien et le nouveau
je me paye par là je suis secrétaire
bilingue dans une entreprise installée à
la nation j'habite boissy-saint-léger
depuis cinq ans tous les matins je
prends le train de 8 heures 26
[Musique]
assez lent
je commence le connaissent par coeur ce
chemin avec le réseau express ça va
changer des choses
pierre ne prendre que sa voiture il va
être content comme ça je me dis que
c'était vraiment serré dkim ans plein de
couleurs et puis même la musique paris
bastille et encore le métro
au total une bonne heure de transport
pour paula tous les matins et tous les
soirs
voici de nouveau voici le voyage
nouvelle formule maintenant toujours
avec paula
ma c'est clair aéré banque est un peu
dur quand même un patin driller tiens il
me manque une hôtesse comme dans les
avions
tintin
le conducteur du pot est heureux de vous
accueillir à bord du métro express 2338
nous voulons à la moyenne de 60 km et
nous effectuerons le trajet
boissy-saint-léger paru un 22 minutes
la minus nation tout le monde descend
voilà
finalement vous avez gagné une en 30
minutes le matin quand on minutes le
soir
donc ça fait une heure si l'unique de
plus chez moi
[Musique]
et sur l'année mais voyons les cent
soixante dix heures et de plus chez moi
quatre niveaux mais plus de trente
escalators comme celui là
[Musique]
trois kilomètres de couloirs mais vous
ne les emprunterez pas tous bien entendu
et maintenant c'est ici qu'il fait bon
flâner pratique très pratique
donc
encore plus pratique parce qu thomas tic
avec des billets magnétique
selon la ratp cent cinquante mille
voyageurs prendront très bientôt le
métro express ont fait un mort dans les
rangs tous ces sentiments que vous
passerez chez vous all it le matin à
l'ecoute 24 heures sur la deux le soir
[Musique]